das klingt nach frankenstein es ist ein
technischer durchbruch auf dem weg zur
künstlichen biologischen computern ein
australisches start up hat menschliche
mini gehirne in petrischalen gezüchtet
und dieses neuronale netz aus hirnzellen
im bioreaktor spielt videospiele
schneller als es eine künstliche
intelligenz auf dem computer lernen
könnte was steckt hinter dieser
spektakulärer meldung und was können
diese mini gehirne aus menschlichen
nervenzellen wirklich nix umsatz im
pfizer bis dreimal pro woche spannender
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasste
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
mini gehirn aus menschlichen
nervenzellen verbunden mit einem
computersystem und genau dieses
neuronale netz aus und ist in der lage
selbstständig zu lernen und dabei ist es
deutlich effizienter als bekannte
künstliche intelligenz systeme dem
australischen biotechnologie startup
korte labs ist damit möglicherweise ein
technischer durchbruch gelungen bis zu
einer millionen nervenzellen haben sich
dabei mit elektroden vernetzt und
spielen videospiele diese mini hirne die
in petrischalen gezüchtet wurden haben
also gelernt den videospiel klassiker
pong zu spielen
das netzwerk aus neuronen brillierte
dabei und vor allem die geschwindigkeit
mit denen die sogenannten displays
lernten verblüffte sogar die fachleute
setzt das unternehmen hat das große ziel
diese technologie bereits in den
kommenden jahren kommerziell nutzbar zu
machen wie genau kann man sich diese
technologie vorstellen und wie ist es
den fachleuten gelungen die vernetzung
der zellen so zu steuern dass sie
konkrete aufgaben lösen können die
spannenden antworten auf all diese
fragen und noch viel mehr gibt es jetzt
hier von mir zahlreiche forschungsteams
haben sich bereits mit netzwerken aus
menschlichen gehirnzellen beschäftigt um
sie zu gehirn ähnlichen strukturen
weiterzuentwickeln denn klar ist das
menschliche gehirn ist ein wahres
wunderwerk immerzu aktiv lernfähig in
der lage komplexe aufgaben zu lösen und
mehrere informationsströme auf einmal zu
verarbeiten und was noch dazu kommt
diesen höchstleistungen verbrauchen
menschliche gehirne weniger als eine
glühbirne in einem kühlschrank an
stromverbrauch 12 bis 24 watt aufgrund
dieser höchstleistung steht das
menschliche gehirn ganz weit oben was
das interesse der forschung angeht wie
großartig wäre es beispielsweise
biologische nervenzellen für die
informatik verfügbar und nutzbar zu
machen siliziumchips also eher als eine
art übergangstechnologie so sieht es
zumindest einer der beiden gründer des
australischen startups karte gesetzt
hohen lenker seine meinung dazu das
menschliche gehirn ist der einzige
wirklich intelligente computer den wir
kennen biologische wesen seien besonders
gut darin sich in einer welt die extrem
variabel ist zurecht zu finden obwohl
ihnen nur wenige unsichere informationen
über ihre umwelt zur verfügung stehen
gehen sie genau mit dieser unsicherheit
meisterhaft um so schon warum sollten
wir das nicht nutzen sagt er was er nun
zusammen mit seinem forschungsteams
geschaffen hat ist eine weltweite
premiere denn die mini gehirne sind nach
angaben von google apps in der lage
zielgerichtete aufgaben zu erfüllen die
lebenden gehirn zellen gezüchtet in
einer petrischale nämlich haben gelernt
das videospiel pong zu spielen dazu sagt
einer der chefentwickler des start-ups
brett caine in einem interview mit new
scientist wir halten es für angemessen
sie cyborg gehirne zu nennen konkret
haben die fachleute sogenannte tisch
brains geschaffen also eben gehirnzellen
in petrischalen diese bestehen aus
800.000 bis einer million euro der
fachbegriff für menschliche nervenzellen
diese miniatur gehirne wurden auf einem
chip aus menschlichen hirn stammzellen
auf einer elektronischen platine mit
einem mikroelektroden netz gezüchtet mit
der hilfe von elektromagnetischen
impulsen können diese neuronen so
selektiv stimuliert werden ähnlich wie
in einem echten gehirn einen kurs löst
dann eine reaktion der nervenzellen aus
und diese antworten können dann
elektronisch ausgelesen werden
ursprünglich wurden diese neuronen aus
dem aus embryonen gewonnen mittlerweile
sind aber neuronen aus
pluripotenten menschlichen stammzellen
im einsatz in der fachsprache werden
stammzellen als pluripotent bezeichnet
wenn sich aus ihnen jedes menschliche
gewebe entwickeln kann allerdings kein
vollständiger organismus diese
pluripotenten menschlichen stammzellen
wachsen in den experimenten von coty
calebs also auf einem raster aus
elektroden und werden dazu
kontinuierlich mit frischer mehr
flüssigkeit versorgt doch wie ist das
gelungen die vernetzung der zellen so zu
steuern dass diese in der lage sind
konkrete aufgaben zu lösen dazu wurde
eine idee des britischen euro forschers
kauf fristen genutzt es geht um das so
genannte prinzip der freien energie das
hatte der wissenschaftler selbst mal
folgendermaßen beschrieben das prinzip
der freien energie besagt dass alle
organismen die überleben der natürlichen
tendenz zur unordnung und auflösung
widerstehen ein weg das zu gewährleisten
besteht darin in einer weise mit der
welt in kontakt zu treten das wäre eine
innere struktur aufrecht erhalten wir
streben nach konstanz und möchten
überraschungen vermeiden die grundidee
dieses konzept kommt ursprünglich aus
der thermodynamik doch der britische
wissenschaftler fürsten hatte es anfang
der 2000er jahre auf lebende systeme die
informationen verarbeiten übertragen
jedes lebewesen hat das ziel so wenig
energie wie möglich zu verbrauchen und
genau das gilt demnach auch für die
verarbeitung von sinnesreizen heißt also
es gibt eine notwendigkeit für
organismen eine konstante innere ordnung
zu erhalten genau das ist der grund
dafür warum alle organismen mit
vorhersagen und hypothesen arbeiten
jedes gehirn versucht demnach also
vorherzusagen was als nächstes kommt und
das bereits bevor der sinnesreize
überhaupt ankommen wenn dann die
wahrnehmung von der vorhersage abweicht
entsteht ein reiz die verknüpfung des
gehirns umzuorganisieren neuronalen
systemen organisieren sich also so dass
sie die vorhersagbarkeit eines stimulus
maximieren so also trainierten die
forschenden die differenz im videospiel
klassiker pong den fällen wurden mit der
hilfe von lichtimpulsen die position des
digitalen balls signalisiert der immer
wieder an einer wand abprallte wenn der
ball sich von rechts oben nach links
unten bewegte bekamen die zellen das
auch mit denn die impulse auf der
platine wurden geografisch genau gleich
bespiegelt wenn ein ball also verfehlt
wurde kam als antwort ein signal mit
negativer konnte aktion das ergebnis
kann sich laut der aktuellen studie
wirklich sehen lassen nennen das
netzwerk von neuronen brillierte in
diesem video spielt vor allem aber gab
es eine überraschung hinsichtlich der
geschwindigkeit mit der die die sprints
dazu lernten es brauchte laut der studie
lediglich fünf minuten das videospiel zu
lernen eine künstliche intelligenz
dagegen braucht im vergleich mehr als
eine stunde um das videospiel punkt zu
meistern der grund für diesen erfolg
liegt der studie zufolge darin dass sich
die neuronalen verbindungen an das
problem angepasst haben das mini gehirn
hat sich also umstrukturiert um die
aufgabe besser zu bewältigen vergleichs
experimente offenbarten dass die
menschlichen neuronen zu dem auch eine
bessere performance zeiten als die
nervenzellen der mäuse die fähigkeit
sich besser zu vernetzen geben die
forscherinnen und forscher hier als eine
erklärungsmöglichkeiten doch die
experimente an aufeinanderfolgenden
tagen offenbarten auch dass die
zellschichten ihre antrainierten
fähigkeiten vergaßen diese mussten dann
neu trainiert werden eine erkenntnis die
erwartbar war so das australische
startup demnach seien diese zellen nicht
auf ein langzeitgedächtnis
spezialisiert nach angaben des start-ups
selbst ist mit diesem experiment ein
erster wichtiger schritt gelungen das
große ziel sei es biologisches computing
bis hin zu einer kommerziell nutzbaren
reife zu bringen klar ist aber auch
anderswo beispielsweise in europa wird
an solchen ideen gearbeitet die
europäische union beispielsweise
finanziert das projekt neue chip
verschiedene start-ups arbeit mir
ebenfalls an der idee stammzellen des
menschlichen gehirns in speziell
entwickelte komplexe schaltkreise zu
integrieren diese sollen dann sowie ein
künstlicher biologischer computer
funktionieren und dieses video hier
liegt mir ganz besonders am herzen bitte
schaut es euch an das ist wirklich
wichtig in diesen zeiten ukraine wir
holen flüchtende da geht es auch darum
wie ihr mit spenden oder sonstwie
wirklich effektiv helfen könnt also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran